there's an expectation now with fans
whether it's the visuals for a record or
the tone or themes to a record but you
know since you know even with the girls
in the guy since Beyonce lemonade
everything else the expectation is hyper
personal you know people want this to be
you they want pieces of you all over you
yeah I reported the reason well I called
it doubled Dutchess cuz it is like the
Duchess but now it's just kind of not
fit it doesn't fit into one style you
know it's a lot of different law a lot
of different flavors yeah on there so
it's like a full meal yeah
but also you know double Duchess it's
kind of the reason I picked that picture
on the front cover is it's a painted on
mask and it's it's kind of like the girl
that that has the mask on with all the
dazzle and all of that but then ripping
tearing the mask off and seeing what's
what the girl is behind the mask and
that's really you know the duality of my
personality and you know I'm I'm
definitely you know extroverted and I
like to have a laugh at everything and
fun I like to dance and all of that but
I'm also you know when you get to my
soul in my heart I'm this really ultra
sensitive you know person underneath and
very just kind of vulnerable and and I
feel really strongly and really
passionately and I love really hard and
so it's it's I'm really I went really
far really deep in there and just kind
of carved out those crevasses and just
kind of laid it all out there I want to
so there's a couple things I want to say
I want to find out where one year head
was into where your heart was with with
a couple of these songs on the record
save it till morning yeah save it till
morning I remember going to Tobi God's
house and he and I wrote big girls don't
cry together back in the day and so it's
just he's kind of like my male therapist
I can really just I trust him I can just
go there and kind of just give him
everything that's been going on and I
have my journals there and I'm just like
I could talk about everything and so we
you know we kind of just go through all
the it sounds it sounds like it sounds
like a fight yeah yeah that one is about
really about you know when people when
you have a fight with somebody and
you're just it gets out of control and
people are just starting to go below the
belt
yeah and say things that they have to
apologize for later or write an apology
letter or any of that it's just like you
know what it's so not worth it because
those things stick with you what was
this from something that happened was
this a fight where this song came from
you know I don't really like to fight
anymore I used to when I was younger I
used to like you know or lose my voice
but no I you know I had a therapist so
you know I I really am a big believer of
like if it's getting too heated if you
get your certain level like take a
breath yeah you know it's not worth
hurting each other because we hurt the
ones that we love the most yeah
sometimes because we feel the most safe
and so it's it's just it's about like
let's not let's not have those ugly
words just sitting there for each other
let's just like take a breath but do you
find that you now have to surround
yourself with other people who feel that
way because if you have people in your
life who don't feel that way you can't
work that philosophy yeah yeah but those
songs like that song is and a lot of the
other songs that are emotional on there
are not about one person yeah they're an
accumulation of different relationships
you say in my life we're all just a
little bit broken yeah a little work
when did you realize that you needed a
little work stumbled through and kind of
figured it out and when did you realize
that you could say publicly that you
needed a little work that you were
somebody who was not perfect I think
I've always yes at that yeah I you know
there's no use in trying yeah I've kind
of always been like a little bit of a
misfit yeah I have fitting a little bit
over here a little bit over here but
it's kind of a little bit just like a
big one big puzzle yeah and yeah and
that
it's just really going through and being
very intimate I wanted to really sound
like I was just singing into your ear
yeah just this close and just just
really just almost as if I was
whispering into your ear it's just very
it's almost like a thought like you know
you're it's almost like I'm thinking
when I'm saying that the verses of that
but then it's it's really about we're
all messed up in some way everybody's
got something right I don't care and you
know what oh well like embrace those
things and have it make you better like
use that to to better yourself because
it really is a lot of the times a battle
in your mind you know all that noise and
those fears and those negative thoughts
those can all really not be that
important to you you know if you just
don't focus on them if you you know kind
of find your path and and find your
positivity in your life and and don't
focus so much on the negative energy you
can really find that that happy road you
know and and I'm constantly just
bouncing back and forth and trying to
get to it and that's just that's just
what that that song is the features on
the record we could talk about these
Rick Ross Nicki Minaj this hot new
singer named axel Jack yeah yeah I want
to start with axel jack axel chat about
discovered you Talia you know I had to
do it he's his voice is just so cute
yeah and when he heard that song he
started singing in French right I
couldn't help myself I would chase him
around and be like sing again it's so
got a few takes that will work and and I
started so cute